ken's got no money he's got no jobs he's  got no car he's got no house he's going  through some stuff margot robbie told us  that whatever we think the barbie movie  is it's not that i would never correct  barbie i would never dream of it she's  right if it's not what you think it is  unless it is and then you know what it  is and then it but i don't think that's  what you think it is that's all i can  say otherwise mattel will come in and  box me out well that's kind of the point  or is it i don't know i still feel like  the energy is alive and can you explain  the kenergy for me do you know what i  mean no you know a can in your life and  then you know that that can has energy  well it's the cannascans per it's the  kennesaw yeah